shocking video shows groom exposed
bride's affair with her brother-in-law
at a wedding
this was in china
now it's a video very long video i don't
know if you want to play it i don't know
it's really up to you if you want to
play the video or not i don't even know
if that is the if the video plays there
oh it's down here it's further on down
i'll read some to you tyler if you want
to play in the background you can you
don't have to but guests of newlyweds in
china can be seen looking on in horror
as a steamy bedroom scene you can't
really see the scene that's why i'm
saying it doesn't matter if you play it
you don't you don't see what's going on
behind
but essentially they get up to the altar
woman and man get up to the altar the
guy plays this bedroom scene featuring
the bride and her husband's
brother-in-law
okay husband's brother-in-law and it
plays out from a projector
and he screams out you think i didn't
know about this
so he humiliates everybody's at the
wedding the wedding is happening
and um
text written over the top of the footage
reads that the groom played video of his
wife cheating on him with her pregnant
sister's husband in front of everybody
so you don't really see
what's going on i was kind of looking
for the video
pregnant sister's husband yes they
neglected to mention that pregnant
sister's husband right so this left
people crazy right they were like what
is going on here
people had mixed emotions about this
some were like why do this publicly well
i know why because he was embarrassed he
was humiliated he was like i want her to
pay i want her to pay
secondly they were like why did he waste
all the money on the way like honey
usually the wife's family pays for the
wedding so he was all in he was like i'm
gonna make you pay for the wedding i
know
that you did the dirty i'm gonna
humiliate you and expose it and then the
thing goes viral
to boot so it's everywhere
other people turn their attention to the
bride it says in the article labeling
her move to throw her flowers wild at
the end she's mad somehow
somehow she's mad she's the one who was
doing the dirty she's mad she throws the
bouquet at him okay
she was embarrassed bottom line okay
tyler can't get enough of this one he's
like scrolling where is there more
where's the update what happened then on
the second page it says they have been
together for two years were engaged for
six months
and
there is a claim that the bride suffered
domestic violence at the hand of the
groom i don't know if that's true
regardless that is not the topic at hand
the topic at hand is
viewers people in the chat folks in the
chat i haven't addressed the chat don't
forget subscribe subscribe subscribe
subscribe hit your like button if you
like all the salacious stuff we're
uncovering right now
but also in the chat you got to tell
tyler and me
do you think this is good to do this if
you found out
that your boyfriend girlfriend was
cheating
would you do something publicly like
this to shame them or is it off limits
good question
i think it's totally fair game i do
i would do something like that i'm not
gonna lie i would enjoy every last
minute then i'd go and i'd eat that
wedding cake like a champ
i would not gonna lie if you like the
short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]